my next guest Matthew Hutchinson
I testify I testify there is none worthy
of worship there is none worthy of
worship besides Allah besides Allah and
I testify and I testify that Muhammad
Muhammad please be upon Him peace be
upon Him is his sermon as his servant
and final messenger and final messenger
now currently known as Ibrahim and I
started to realize that the enemy of my
enemy was in fact my friend the same
people who want to send me to war put me
in debt and turn my life into a
prostitute they were the same people
that were telling me Islam was bad named
after Abraham
and this young man who's still young but
not confused anymore at one point he was
confused didn't understand why the world
around him made no sense living without
purpose but eventually he got to
engaging and researching and trying to
understand why everything around him was
not only engaging everybody was engaging
in sin but also promoting it
he looked into Christianity and all the
other religions and a lot of the things
from the Theology and and whatnot that
came with it didn't make sense and then
he also looked into Islam and now he's
on a Dean show we want to hear his story
how he ended up accepting Islam why he
accepted Islam I came across one of his
videos I want to go ahead and let you
guys see this he's been making these
short clips really profound let's take a
look at this and then we'll bring out
our next guest Ibrahim here on the dean
show
this is our religion Islam Islam this is
the teacher
show
[Music]
and then I realized that the whole
anti-muslim propaganda that we've been
fed in the West Was a trick music is
Haram I've always knew that music was a
scam I've always knew that modern day
music was a child when you look at cardi
B and what she's managed to get women to
become of it if you went up to a woman
20 years ago and said
you're going to abort your babies and
you're going to be a they would go
no I'm not but if you put the nice beat
over it they can insert the programming
and I'm speaking back and forth with my
Muslim friends and they said music is
Haram we don't do music it takes you off
the path I thought well there you go
Eddie is taking this Amana of the people
very seriously he was just sharing a
story with me that they had some benches
inside that needed to be moved and Eddie
together Father and Son were lifting
these benches join us in this project
inshallah so we can establish a
beautiful Dean Center assalamualaikum
greens of Peace how you doing brother
Ibrahim
doing very well very well as um this is
one of those moments I don't want to say
it's surreal but um I was watching a lot
of your stuff a while ago I mean I only
took the shahada about three months ago
and I I phoned you through Owen Benjamin
and I was watching a lot of your stuff a
couple years ago even earlier on in the
year and now to be speaking to you it's
quite I don't want to say the word
surreal but it's um makes me feel quite
proud you know especially because you
have such a great platform and you have
such a great message and for me to have
the the honor to come on and share my
opinion and my experiences which are
quite unique as um it's a pleasure
mashallah
and I'm very proud of you young brother
Ibrahim to have someone like you who's
Thinking Beyond all of the debauchery
and all of the nightclubs and partying
and whatnot he's he's gotten to a point
in his life he's taken life serious and
that's what we need young men to do to
go ahead and stay take up that role of
the Future Leaders tomorrow because
you're not you're not going to do that
just getting drunk every night smoking
dope smoking weed and switching ladies
left and right it's just a it's a path
to destruction that's crazy man I can
see why it's promoted and I don't want
to start this off in kind of like a
theory sort of way
but I was I was thinking for a long time
now can you imagine and I'm not uh
backbanging people it's just an
observation I have could you imagine in
15 20 years when my generation are the
people making roads and the people
building infrastructure like what
they're fed when they're young they
don't learn any skills they don't have a
moral compass their life is completely
undone yeah it's all about what can I
get now that will make me feel good
regardless of the implications that has
on your friends your family or on the
macro level like every young man now
prior to 22 is in debt he has no skills
everything he's been taught is kind of a
lie to a degree and I think people go
away with that maybe in the 60s with the
Baby Boomers but I think now is the
economy starting to the snake is
starting to squeeze I think for a lot of
people and this is one thing I noticed
and I was worried with to a degree was
that when when our generation gets older
we're responsible for things I don't
know how these systems are going to
continue to thrive I don't think they
will because people are just so blatant
and competent and distracted and I'm
very glad and whether it was me that
seen through it individually or whether
I had assistance from a higher power
which is my theory I'm very glad
mashallah that I've been able to see
through these things because I think the
road that young men and women are fed
now outside of Islam is just straight
straight to hell you know yeah I like
what you said there because a person can
have wealth and money and some of the
most corrupt people have all all of that
they have everything they have the power
to status but truly when the Creator God
Almighty Allah loves someone he gives
them understanding of their purpose of
the Deen this way of life Islam
so uh this is a gift a beautiful gift
and I want to start off with talking
you're from Scotland from Scotland yeah
still still here unfortunately but yeah
yeah cool accent so that's uh from the
right next to UK as in the UK it's uh I
think that's kind of why a lot of my
videos have popped off to a degree like
I'm growing in the beard now which makes
me look a bit I guess to a degree more
masculine to a degree but I think some
of the reasons that a lot of my videos
started to blow up a lot is because they
when I had the shaved face and the quiff
haircut and the tattoos I think when
people see my face on the video they
expected me to start singing like a
Justin Bieber song or something and then
they click on it and I start screaming
about Sharia law
um and I think that that sort of
oxymoron that
um you know shock value as uh led to
people being so intrigued as to what I
have to say but I'm growing in the beard
now so yeah
I want to just take a uh a minute to go
ahead because when we say certain when
when they hear us people out there and
they hear Sharia I just uh equate that
to uh the Ten Commandments you got the
Sharia that's mentioned over 250 times
in the Bible this is divine guidance
that comes from the from the Creator and
is built on the pure monotheism tell me
what actually got you interested you
said you started off looking into
Scotland what's the primary religion way
of life that people are born into their
their parents upon is it is it
Christianity
uh it's not really I would say it's more
I I actually have a weird way of looking
at it because I wouldn't say anyone's
really religious in the UK it's not a
Christian country why would but I would
say
is that people aren't atheists you know
I think people do have a religion the
same sort of story fractively repeats
over and over again so if you look at
young women in in the UK they do have a
religion the the nightclub is their
Church cardi B is their Prophet
um WAP by oh hold on hold on hold on
night nightclub I like that night club
that's their Church all right their
cardi B cardi B is what cardi b as their
profit is their profit yep
um the the scripture is a Megan the
stallion song
is drugs
communion okay communities drugs they're
an understanding in Christian their holy
water is vodka
oh the um they're charged day is a
Saturday they're always on a Saturday
night and then if you look at like the
sacrifice was the boyfriend that they
loved that they cheated on with a
basketball player and then the the
second coming the miracle is that
basketball player texting them back it's
a religion you know and so people can
pretend they're atheists but they're not
they just replace the same story and
they they they pull in Haram influences
and and take the story but take out God
they take out the prophet peace be upon
them and they fill it with Haram
so in the UK
I just think a lot of people are
confused I wouldn't say they're even
atheists I would just say they're
nihilistic they're they're depressed
they have no hope
um they have no guidance no moral
compass so that was probably the most
confusing part for me was just not
understanding why things were promoted
why things were seen as normal it was
very difficult to find an adult to take
advice from because all the adults I was
looking up to were riddled with sin and
riddled with with Haram so it's just it
is atheist to a degree but they always
take
um they'll take something else and make
that their religion like I said with the
the cardi B sort of thing so yeah I like
this breakdown I like this I heard
someone else so so give a breakdown
where they have these um the stadium and
then you have the people with you know
the the makeup and everything and
they're almost like uh worshiping these
teams and whatnot then you got the you
know the modern day uh the uh the big
Arenas and whatnot and pretty much it's
like acts of worship so I like how you
broke this down this is like the
concerts and people you know for
idolizing and yeah worshiping worshiping
worshiping these celebrities you've seen
have you seen like uh that when I there
was a show a long time ago meet your
favorite celebrity and then when they
would meet them they would just be going
like crazy crying and whatnot and that's
interesting that's one thing that kind
of um changed because my life's kind of
went in a weird Direction the past
um say 15 months I mean I became a part
of a
undertake's war room and to see guys
that you used to as a young guy when
you're hopeless you do kind of look for
Idols to drag you out of the pit you
want to know what they know you want to
download their brain so you can
implement it into your own life and now
that I can kind of network and speak to
these people
whether it be as a business associate or
as a friend that idle thing is so clear
as day to me now because these you have
young women who are smarter stronger and
prettier more wise stronger on The Dean
but they'll idolize a woman who is lower
than them in every measurable metric
like a cardi B
and it makes no sense and since I've
went from idolizing these people to
communicating with them you realize
they're no different than you they're
just people they have the same abilities
to the same mind granted to them by
Allah as you do and the idle thing's a
big one because I think that's how they
push in a lot of their their programming
as they do it through these false Idols
you know but even if you if you remove
and I notice this when you remove God
from a society you do an answer that's
kind of replace it with satanism so a
lot do you remember when um the the
Balenciaga Scandal came about yeah yes I
remember that yes yeah and a lot of
people were and I actually had to go a
go at this on my old Instagram a lot of
people rightfully saw uh the men were
pointing out that it's child sacrifice
to a degree the women were saying the
same thing and I went no you're doing it
as well and people were saying you know
when you look at these alleged uh
scenarios where people will do their
little rituals and then they'll
sacrifice a kid to Bow and I go you do
that you're pointing out but you do it
what is fornication you do your little
ritual you do your dance and then you
get uh the a word I don't know if it's a
trigger word you get an abort t-i-o-n
it's the same sort of thing and these
guys that were were pointing that out
this is one of the reasons why Islam
became so clear to me that it was the
truth is that these guys were pointing
out that Balenciaga thing and I go you
watch pornography every single day where
did they get those girls from
where do you think they get them from
it's the same thing as trafficking it's
abuses the the uh the attacking of
children and the woman that were
pointing out I said you've got aborty
ions to go buy an Audi on finance and go
to Ibiza
so when you remove God from a society
and you and you flood it with money and
I think it's really bad now because they
flooded it with so many Comforts and I
always say as things are increasing in
price and this wouldn't happen in Sharia
law by the way as things are increasing
in price and you can't buy a house
without rebar you can't buy a car
without Reba why is cardi B's music
still free why is all the pornography
and the internet still free why is all
the music still free why is all this
satanic entertainment why is it all
still free it's because you're the
product and there's an analogy I've used
in the past which is if a if a farmer
wants to milk a goat he can't just milk
the goat he has to get consent so what
is it because if you try milk ago it
kicks you it runs away it gets
aggressive so you give it feed you give
the goat feed and then it'll come along
it'll sedate it'll mellow out and then
you can milk it and if you're things
like Instagram feed Twitter feed YouTube
feed why are these things all free it's
because you're the product and it's
there is there to to mellow out the guys
you know what I mean there's lots of
things that I I don't I still don't
understand like how only fans is not
illegal how is all the porn on the
internet not illegal if you look at
America
which was a Christian country why is
your entire Financial system based on
usury which is one of the number one
sins in the Bible and I think it's
because they give the men just like you
give goats feet to sedate them you give
the men corn syrup fluoride
um free sex with women they don't have
to marry them anymore they can get rid
of the kid and then the men lose that
drive they have and they allow this
Haram to plague you know so it's a very
complex world and it was certainly way
more confusing when I didn't have Islam
because and I think as a guy with the
problem that I had and if you look at I
think we could agree on this if we had
to go to war tomorrow
but we had a family at home and friends
we loved I think we would do it men will
sacrifice things and take huge risks
when there's a glimmer of hope at the
end in the tunnel and I think what
they're doing now and this is what I
experienced is there seemed like there
was no hope so there's nothing to fight
for you know and I think what they
always do is they turn men and women
against each other
and now the same people that you would
have died for you know see them as your
enemy and that that completely removes
all hope from the equation and that's
the problem I think that's why people
are depressed I think that's why suicide
for men is shooting through the roof I
think it's because there seems to be no
hope at the end of the tunnel and I can
tell you because I've lived in both
worlds when I reverted to Islam it it
was so Divine it's like all of that
hopelessness just washed away you know
so what were you doing before Islam
well it's interesting because when I was
younger obviously you're engaged in all
of the the Haram sort of activities the
clubbing the fornication
the sterility the indulging that you
don't really consider even things like
lies that you would do
you just see it as a I'm here I have to
get mine and that doesn't really matter
what happens
um but as interesting is that as I kept
on doing that I kind of got less and
less interested in it and you know it's
actually been I think we should had it
three months ago but it's been over a
year martial law since I last went to a
nightclub and nearly over a year since I
last drank alcohol because I think and I
don't know if it was divine intervention
how I could see through it but other
people couldn't but I remember the last
time I was at a club
and they shot at three in the morning
and it was about half one and I was
sitting there and I was looking at two
girls twerking and I just thought some
guys probably cried over you and now
you've just you've degraded yourself to
nothing more than a vessel for a
stranger's lost and then I would see
young guys who don't have a house they
don't have skills they're secretly
depressed and they were doing little 50
Cent dances and stuff and I thought
you've got work on Monday you have
better things to do and you're only here
because you're a slave to your lost
because of all the things you've been
exposed to as a young man so did I I
took the Shahara three months ago but I
would say I've been
diverting to a more Islamic life for a
long time now the problem was it took me
so long to take the shahada and publicly
announce it because I was then trying to
explain to people in the west what
you're doing is it's not Freedom it's
actually the chains that are enslaving
you you know but I always say they
always sell these things under the guise
of Freedom so they'll say you're free to
women are free to murder their offspring
they're free to sleep around their men
are free to do whatever but they're not
freedoms they're actually the chains
that would enslave you and you could you
could do them on a six foot jail cell
and they're the really nihilistic
hopeless feeling I had for a while was I
was trying to explain to these people
what you're doing is not good
and they're just not interested you know
it's like going into uh uh let's just
say because I don't want to say any
trigger Wars but let's just say you go
into an LG TV bar and you explain to
them that sodomy isn't good for you they
don't care they want to do it and if
you're just wasting your time telling
them and when I reverted to Islam and
publicly announced it finally having
people around me that understood what I
was saying and and believed it was was
is actually one of the biggest blessings
I've had in my life you know because you
can have money you can have influence
you can have intelligence but if you
don't have people around you to share
that with there's no point and I I
really want to give a kudos to the
Islamic community for being so welcoming
and so
I will say strong on the dean you know
because there's been loads of
persecution on on Islam over the past 10
15 20 years especially and I fell for it
when I was young
and to see these guys still be like
yourself still be so strong and and firm
on the dean it's just it's incredible to
see and it's incredible to see people
like yourself who are coming up coming
and showing that you are part of a life
just like myself you you grow up and uh
you're in the nightclubs and then you
work throughout the week and then the
you're just excited for the repeat you
know to hook up culture and whatnot
chasing your lusts and desires is like a
it's like a pit an empty pit and you can
never associate yourself you're always
thirsty for it but to see young young
men like yourself coming out from this
and then being programmed with
everything that's out there and then
coming to finally realization that there
is a purpose and then you find it in
Islam how were you before what was your
what was your investigation like when
you were like okay did you just did
someone introduce you to Islam were you
like looking at all the different other
religions how did how did Islam stand
out from all the other man-made
religions that are out there there that
people don't think like oh that's good
for him he it just brings him peace you
know well I'll jump to Buddhism or I'll
jump to uh Sikhism I'll jump to this
there are religions are a lot are pretty
much all the same what made you conclude
that indeed Islam because obviously you
wouldn't have been following it if it
wasn't from the Divine from the Creator
with Clear Proof and evidence what did
it for you family well I would say the
first and I really want to give some
some credibility here because I've never
really publicly stated the influence
that he's had on my life and the reason
I want to share it with you is because
you know him and I would say the biggest
influence I had with discovering Islam
was a Owen Benjamin who's not even a
Muslim himself oh and he he hasn't took
the shahada but how's he doing how's
Owen doing he's very good I I speak to
him from time to time very very
fractively in case I have any anything
interesting to say but he's he's not
Muslim but he's broke all the Spells
regarding Islam and that was a big one
for me because and there's a saying that
the enemy of your enemy is your friend
yeah and when I was looking at the this
system and people call it the Matrix
which I don't really know if it's real I
think it's just all contracts and offers
in my opinion and I say that because no
one can make you take a loan no one can
make you divorce your wife they don't
put a gun to your head they have to get
you to do it so does the Matrix exist
it's Up For Debate like no one can make
you watch the news and let it influence
you
um but once I started to see the people
that wanted me in debt and wanted my
wife future wives and daughters and only
fans and and wanted my sons addicted and
molested and broken if they're telling
me that Islam is bad does it not tell me
that it might be good
um and I think and the reason I want to
give credibility to Owen specifically is
because he's kind of been the voice
that's in my ear for a long time been in
my ear
um and he broke down all these events
which I don't think occurred the way
they were described like
um and I won't say them exactly because
they might be triggers but 7-Eleven
there was a few
um concert circumstances that occurred
in the UK and when you see through the
lie and what the the actual intentional
of those events was it was to get you to
go overseas and to attack Muslims
because they don't accept Reba they
don't exact LG TV and when I started to
see that all these wars and lies and
spells were not because Muslims were
extremists it's not because Muslims
weren't they are intolerant but what are
they intolerant of they were intolerant
of the things that make you a slave
they're intolerant of your money being
backed by nothing they're intolerant of
turning your wives mothers and daughters
in the horse quite frankly
um I originally looked at Christianity
and I think that was more just because I
guess you could see an ethnic thing to a
degree as being like a white guy in
Europe you're instantly drawn towards
Christianity and again I have to give
credit to Owen is when I was reading the
Bible a lot of stuff didn't make sense
and your King James wrote a Bible and he
used to bang animals and I thought why
couldn't I write one then and just
rewrite everything and when you look
into the word Bible's never mentioned
once wait repeat that again who used to
do what King James the the kge is the
main Bible written yeah he used to do
bestiality get out of here yep people
can fact check this fact check that I'm
pretty sure it has to do that
um and I thought okay that makes that
makes no sense that's that's the that's
the person who wrote the the that's the
Bible that it's named after him King
James King James James yeah he's very
sinful man and he wrote a Bible and that
made no sense to me and you look at the
the Bible the word Bible was never
mentioned once there were Christians
that were mentioned once don't even get
me started on the Trinity
um I have theories regarding the journey
which I want to mention later in fact
I'll write it down because I have a very
interesting one that I don't like to
hear that considered
um and if you look at Jesus Jesus spoken
um Aramaic and if you translate God in
Aramaic it means a lot a lot it means a
lot yeah and I thought well there you go
he did Ramadan I believe when I looked
into that and then you look at Paul who
wrote the New Testament and it
contradicts everything the the Old
Testament said about how Jesus would
never return how there was only 12
Apostles
and then Paul met him on the road to
Damascus with no no Witnesses doesn't
make much sense and you know what I will
say as well as there's a saying in the
Bible that is you'll know them by their
fruits and if you look at Christian
countries what are their fruits their
divorce rate 60 their entire Financial
system is based on usury where it takes
a 21 year old a hundred years to buy a
house which would have cost them 30k 30
years previously yet all of these Haram
things are still free and the fourth
biggest career choice in America I
believe is only fans and I just thought
you you guys well repeat that last part
again the fourth I believe only fans is
the fourth biggest career choice in
America wow wow wow I heard that
um a couple months ago so who knows but
when you see all these things going on
and then all they want to do is debate
about the trinity
and obviously the Trinity I don't even
want to get into it because it's so
asinine and stupid
um but they didn't want to explain it to
you when you have a question about these
things they just attack you and if you
look at the whole
um tea with no sin cast the first stone
which is what they say they forget the
part after it which is rising sun no
more so in my opinion and of course on
the micro if you follow Jesus's
teachings peace be upon him you're going
to have a fantastic life but on the
macro as an Institute it seems very much
to me that it's a place where people can
go and they can condemn others because
they're already saved allegedly
and they can condemn condemn condemn
condemn and it doesn't matter if they
don't follow their own teachings it
doesn't matter if they don't take
inspiration and take advice from Jesus
it doesn't matter if they don't follow
the laws in Leviticus because they're
already saved and the fruits of that
rotten tree are poisonous and you can
see them in the west now
um so yeah but with the Trinity I have I
have a very interesting Theory and it
involves a return of the dejao which I
think and I know you'll know this when
you look at the end times prophecies
that almost everything prophesies
regarding the ends of times are kind of
true and there's ones that aren't really
up for debate like there's one the the
prophet said peace be upon him the woman
will be clothed yet unclothed and if you
go back 1400 years there they don't know
what spandex is they don't know that
nowadays every woman walks around in
essence with spray paint on
but just imagine this say you're with
the jail returning and I have a theory
that you know when you drink alcohol
when you and I think you're you're a
Reaver as well yourself Eddie aren't you
so when you when you drink alcohol you
start to get thoughts in your head that
I don't even think are yours you start
to want to fornicate with women you
wouldn't want to fornicate with you
start wanting to fight bouncers who are
seven feet tall who could marry you
but whose thoughts are those in your
head because it's not rational it's not
logical they just pop into your head you
know and it's almost like by giving
consent to shatan you're allowing him to
put thoughts in your head because you
know shitan can't strike us with
lightning you can't drop a tree on our
head he needs our consent you know the
devil has to make you do it to yourself
and I think if you look at the the
institutions of Christianity and I don't
want to get into too much detail but if
you look at what's going on with the
Catholic church I don't think I need to
explain and the Orthodox Church which in
my opinion is just a protection racket
now
it's like they became so sinful and so
void of what their own scripture was
telling them that thoughts are popping
into their head which aren't theirs
because they've consented to it by doing
sin if you were the the jail returning
wouldn't it be because the Trinity makes
no sense
who did Jesus pray to you know it makes
no sense if you were the jail returning
wouldn't it be convenient if the largest
religion on the planet was convinced
that God could take the form of man
because then when you return it's far
more easier to have followers isn't it
if they believe God could take the form
of man when you return
why wouldn't it why why couldn't you be
God why wouldn't the largest religion on
the planet follow you so well when I see
things like that on such a large scale
which are so asinine and stupid and
makes such little sense I think it's
metaphysical I think there's a spiritual
realm that we can't see and I think
they're involved now I don't think it's
man creating these things I think it's
uh shatan funneling it absolutely and
that's why I like what you just said you
know when you say talk about this
convincing people that God Almighty has
been was a man walked the earth I mean
that's why theology that's why
understanding the the true concept of
the creator of the tawheed because a lot
of these things that people really like
about Islam you know the the guidelines
the guidance you know the clear do's and
don'ts and some people come to Islam
because some of these other things but
now what keeps them in Islam is the
theology is the tohi the pure monotheism
now you're able to differentiate and you
don't fall into these trips and tracks
you know the guy Almighty is one a
long-worthy worship that he has the
perfect names and attributes nobody's
all hearing no seeing so someone comes
to you with some mystical stuff and says
hey you know I'm talking to this Sheikh
or this person and he can be in another
country another room no no or there's
these like 12 uh or 15 17 different
shakesy moms they know everything hear
everything no no that violates the
Towhee the pure monotheism so when you
know this and then your worship is
devoted only to the one God you know not
to a dead person in the ground none of
these things that that keeps you in
Islam it keeps you awake to all of the
man-made things that are out there
trying to go ahead and deviate you from
the truth so this is so so important
that that people understand these things
talk to me about um so now you're a
young man you're out there indulging in
what young men indulge in uh so your
parents upbringing was uh
we talked a little bit about what people
are really atheists but were they
practicing Christian Christians
what did your parents raise you as it's
just I got things atheist you would say
you get into the school system and and
then okay so more secular yes that's
exactly the word okay all right so did
you did you take a time to investigate
any other religions or when you got
exposed to Islam you knew this was it
yeah it's very obvious and again it's
there you'll know them by their fruits
and just to see how the and I guess a
lot of big influencers are saying this
and I'm not just saying it because they
say it and it sounds nice of the year
but
Islam is the last one and I think it's
just survival of the fittest and I think
the cream always Rises to the top and
even though all of this stuff is being
hammered and hammered and hammered and
hammered Islam still has a family unit
it still has a moral compass you can't
see that really any other religion on
the planet and just the theological side
of things backed up and made it complete
sense what's the whole Jesus thing as
well when you make him God and he was
crucified what you're then saying to a
young kid is
that he goes who's that dead guy over
there and you go that's God that's the
guy who made you so what you're saying
is
God
took the form of man and he followed the
laws that he created but sinful men his
own creation despite not following his
own laws garnered more power than him
and were able to kill God
so then if you're a young kid why follow
the tenants because if people who don't
are more powerful than you then why
would you why would you care to follow
them you know so the theology side of
Islamic made total sense but it is just
so you'll know the mother fruits and to
see how firm Islam and you know what I
really want to I kind of want to
apologize to a degree because when all
that propaganda was rolling out and I
can give myself leeway with it because I
was 14 15 and I didn't know any better
but all of the propaganda that was fired
at Islam and Muslims to still be because
if it was me getting that level of
propaganda and hatred I wouldn't have
tolerated it and I would have went nuts
but to see how calm and and respectful
and firm they are still it's incredible
to witness martial law you know and it's
interesting you mentioned uh you were
influenced someone by also Owen Benjamin
when I had a conversation with a one
Benjamin for people who don't know Bowen
Benjamin Benjamin in a nutshell he was
uh he's a famous comedian
an actor or actor commitment or comedian
act I don't know if he did some acting
did he yeah mainly a comedian right and
he was in Hollywood he was on many times
in a Joe Rogan show he also uh was a
script writer for the louder for Crowder
and he also wrote the one of the songs
for uh Tommy Robinson he was uh somebody
who hated uh Islam and Muslims and then
something happened
and he changed his ways and he was
thinking like wow these guys when they
say Jesus they say peace be upon him and
he saw the programming that that that
happened and he got out of it and when
we had a discussion me and him I really
encouraged people to watch that he calls
as many as followers the the Bears yeah
my whole thing on YouTube is Lord Bear
yeah yeah so when many of the Bears
watched uh our talk we're talking about
goats and we're talking about Farm life
and then we're talking about just uh
many of uh the things that he believed
before and he and his nice in his
humorous ways uh he went and um
explained what he would how he couldn't
believe you know he was programmed to
believe Muslims were doing this and that
it was just all nonsense and and then
many of the Bears who watched uh us
really have a down-to-earth conversation
they also like almost like the spell was
off they saw that you know uh there was
more to it and they couldn't believe how
they were they were just uh misled to I
have to I have to give him credibility
and I I don't know if you'll see this I
think I mentioned to him
um on a live stream a few weeks ago that
I'd be on here but um yeah I can't thank
him enough for what he's done and people
don't know who he is if you think guys
like Andrew Tate are band you have no
idea what Banning is when you see what
he's went through and he's not Muslim
but he in essence lives a sharia-esque
life you know and he has that monotheism
behind him he's he's an Essence a Muslim
but he's not too because she had it yet
right
um and just one man who won't compromise
on obvious lies because that was always
what kind of scared me as a Young Man
during
um let's say snovad 91 to see all these
guys that you would look up to are meant
to be strong men who should have a
strong moral compass and yeah what is
right above their passions or come first
it was very scary because you don't have
anyone to look up to and I think that's
how this Mass hypnosis of of dunya's hit
the world because these guys are so lost
and Afraid and then they bring in Idols
who promote Haram and then young guys
they got wrong with it but just to have
one guy who didn't compromise and didn't
didn't let Earthly Pleasures get above
what is right and I I people like that
are persecuted quite often but I want to
make this statement public in case guys
like this guys like Owen who are
watching this and have the same role you
have no idea the effect that can have on
the world because look now I'm building
diagram which will help millions of
Muslims across the world get off this
propaganda Haram social media which
pushes sin
so just one guy who who doesn't
compromise can have such an insane
Snowball Effect on the younger
generation when we we look up to them so
I can't really thank on and off and I've
never publicly publicly said that so I
hope he sees this yeah so to see someone
like him to be influenced by the Hate
Machine the hate provocateurs and a
clear islamophobe and then next to you
know boom he's uh he was on The Dean
show and now he's inspiring others to
actually inspire you so much that you
actually accepted Islam yeah 100 it's
crazy because when when you're young and
you're getting fed all these lines about
Islam there's something quite funny
actually because I've never lied and
ironic this is a cool Owen Hazard I
might be wrong but I'm not lying and I
was never lying when I thought this but
I was in the panic mode that Islam is a
war of hate uh war of hate a religion of
hate and they're gonna come and they're
gonna do all these bad things and I used
to do you actually this is this is what
you actually believed when I was like 15
though you know so you're young and you
don't repeat that again so you believed
you were programmed to believe that
Islam is what religion of hate the t
word that has an e and an R yeah
and then I was very afraid of the fact
that Muhammad's been the number one name
in the UK for the past 10 years and it's
funny because the first five years of
that statistic I was scared of it
because I thought oh no how dare you
they're all going to come get us and
then since I seen through the lie it's
not my favorite statistic on the planet
it's great you know so so just for guys
to dismantle these lies because I think
when you look at something like Sharia
law
how demonized has that been in the
western world but if you applied that
overnight 99.9 of the problems in the
world would dissipate like that you know
if you look at the depression the
financial issues the the how criminals
get away with things how these these
Banks can get bailed out how things like
porn or legal how only fans is legal if
you applied Sharia law overnight
it's gone
but these westerners will still refute
it and and push it down even though it
would save them from all the problems
they had you know so once you can see
through that that shady Mist spell Islam
becomes very clear to you that is the
true way to live you know
there's one example of what you just
said in the
uh implementing the zakat so the Divine
Divine guidance that got us sent down
which is in the Five Pillars and one of
them is the cat and the the scholars of
Islam say that if the zakat was
implemented if everybody paid their 2.5
percent that that poor due tax that's
the poor that's their right upon the
people of uh who are more uh who have
more wealth than them this would
eradicate poverty so this is 100 I think
that's why um the Ottoman empire grew so
big because of the financial
implications you know like people in the
west I'll get taxed 60 and they're like
100k a year now it doesn't what what a
house cost you 500 and you still get
taxed 60 every year you don't need that
tax it's because your money is backed by
nothing and I can and I I take
Industries like I said earlier how are
these things free Instagram I don't
think makes a penny the porn industry
doesn't make a penny they can just print
money and give it to them to keep them
afloat yeah and when you look at that I
think it's the 2.5 percent it's a cat
for non-muslims in a Sharia Society is
that not far better than paying 60 and
still being in poverty you know but they
won't accept it because the programming
runs so deep yeah this is for for Muslim
now the the tax you wouldn't even have
this whole thing with taking all your
wealth that goes towards you know
uh what you were talking about so this
is another example tell me this uh tell
me this Ibrahim when you when we opened
up the program and there was a short
video of you talking about cardi B and
how they get these lyrics into the to
the music I also heard Owen talk about
this also the the my the um
the virus that's in the malware
and you've finally understood it you
were like okay now I understand why uh
these uh when we say music we say
usually it's the musical instruments in
that so now with all of these songs that
are out there and again
go ahead and talk about this this is
something really really uh to see
someone like you discussing this to be
up on this you know to be understanding
like how this poison how they're getting
this into you to your minds through all
these uh musical beats and instruments
can you elaborate on that yeah 100 and I
I always say and you agree that shitan
can't make you do anything he can he
can't strike you with lightning he can't
make a car crash into you he has to get
your consent to do it because then the
sin is on you and it's not his fault and
even if you're not religious if you look
at archetypes like a vampire you have to
let him into the house he can't just
come in yeah and I always use the
there's there's a few different
demographics and and cultures that have
changed so quickly over the past hundred
years that make no sense and I use the
analogy of if you took a woman and I
still I actually want to make a point on
this later about rhetoric so let me just
quickly write that down because I have a
very important point to make about that
but if you took a woman in the 50s and
told her you're going them your four
kids you have there you're gonna murder
them when they're in your womb you're
going to leave your husband you're going
to go into an office and work for money
which isn't real and you're gonna go out
at the weekend and you're going to get
with guys you don't care about you and
will leave you and you're gonna die at
50 from a drug overdose because you're
depressed they would have went no I'm
not doing it they would have slapped you
and the husband would have battered you
so what they do is because people just
don't accept that so what they do is
they give you
and then cardi B comes in when you're up
when you're listening to it and cardi B
comes and makes it sound good she makes
it sound cool look at her she has all
this money which they printed into
Oblivion and gave it to her and then you
want to be cool like the idol you're
worshiping and now you're accepting it
not only will you accept it but you'll
defend it you'll defend it and just
before I move on to the rest of the
music thing the point I want to make
about rhetoric is I want to make this
clear
they will use different spells to get
you to accept things and one of the
things they do is the word things
differently
so when you look at the the LG TV agenda
they will say love is love acceptance
Freedom it's not love is love it's not
Freedom it's not acceptance It's called
sodomy it's rectum trauma that's what it
is me and Eddie can get on well I can
love
um the things I'm doing the last thing
you want to do to something you love is
sodomize it and it's called Sodom and
Gomorrah for a reason
because your body you eat food your body
digests it and it excretes it in waste
and what they're trying to do is it's
the inversion they're trying to get you
to put your thingy where all the waste
and death is that's what it is it's not
Lover's love and if you look at the
feminism thing
they said um Freedom my body my choice
all this sort of stuff it's not my body
my choice it's not Freedom it's not boss
you killed your Offspring for
money that isn't real to pay off debt
which isn't real that's actually what it
is so they use these spells and rhetoric
or music to get you to accept things
and even other demographics okay if you
look at um the violent crime of African
Americans in the USA go back to the 50s
it was the same so what did they do they
they bring in 50 Cent they bring in all
these idols and they'll sing songs about
how gang banging and shooting and
killings cool and because you like the
beat you'll know go up to an
African-American family in the 50s and
tell the guy you're going to leave your
family and you're going to start
shooting people in the street they would
have rejected it you look at London
London was one of the most Pious
beautiful cities in the planet if you
went up to those
aristocratic men and said you're going
to be the staff capital of the world
they would have said no so they bring in
Idols who promote violence promote gangs
and and because of the beat behind it
they can say the same thing but without
the beat you don't accept it with the
beat you accept it and then you look at
Islam it's Haram and then the prophet
peace be upon him said and there will be
I believe he said I'm paraphrasing and
there will be those who believe that the
the instrument is good or something like
that it's clear that it's not you know
so they do these things to get you to
accept things
um and then you've always got to watch
over again why are these things free
when a young family can't buy a house
without Reba why can he still buy the
same girl who he would have married they
can't buy a house without reborn start a
family why could he buy her only fans
for 7.99 a month it's free because
you're the product it's cheap because
you're the product you know they make
the money they're not interested in
money they make it if you look at
internet pornography it's 35 of the
traffic on the internet they don't
charge a penny for it they don't make
money they print it and they give you
these industries just like they give
goats feed
to sedate you and mellow you out so you
don't realize what's actually going on
you don't Rebel not even rebelled an
aggressive way but start to make changes
you know if you're comfortable you're
never going to move earlier you
mentioned the War Room did uh did Andrew
Tate have any influence also his uh when
he ended up that I think that's so you
accepted Islam three months ago he he
accepted Islam what probably close to
half a year ago now no no it's not has
it been has it been six months six
months what's interesting about the
Andrew thing is um I took the shahada
three months ago but I actually got a
Quran
November last year I think it was so it
was before Andrew Rivera I believe yeah
I wouldn't say he had a huge influence
on it but of course it's always good to
see a guy of that caliber over there and
and for a guy and I don't really look
into what he's up to too much today just
because I'm so focused on what I'm doing
but if a guy of that magnitude can
revert
and stop publicly promoting Haram and
give it up and set an example for young
men all the the false Idols were given I
don't want to use the word Idol because
you shouldn't have any but let's say
role models we don't have any good ones
so to see a guy of that because he could
have had older women all the money all
the Indulgence and to give it up for
what is right at that level I I have a
huge respect for him but it's
interesting because um
you know when I when I bought a Quran I
went to a war in me up and I was
speaking to a couple of the brothers in
there and they were telling me about
goosel wooden just teaching me the the
fine Delicacies of the faith and the the
some the simple things that you have to
do and it was so to a degree I would say
effortless you would think something
like that would be a huge deal for a guy
like me but it wasn't you you come in
you start reading the the small
practices are introduced to you and then
another meet up another brother who was
in the organization said you want to
take the shahada and you would think I
would have been like oh um I don't know
I'm not sure
um or let me think of it I just went
yeah sure it was almost like it was
divine it was so smooth and effortless
there was no resistance to the decision
you know what I mean it was just so
smooth and then three months later
you're uh it was funny because my
shahada actually was in a it was Juma
and the biggest mosque in my area and I
went in and I thought it would be a
private thing I thought I'd be like you
and the Imam in a room privately doing
it and then they wheeled me off in front
of everybody in front of 80 90 brothers
and I did it it was probably the most
nerve-wracking moment of my life because
you just you don't want to be
disrespectful
and then the rest is history is the best
decision I've ever made in my life and
mashallah you know have you met uh
there's there's a few Brothers there
that also who are good friends with uh
Andrew like Jewel see if you met uh have
you seen Joe speak from time to time in
fact one time once diagram he also for
people to know this is a really good
friend of Andrew he also someone looked
into Islam and he's a very intelligent
man he ends up accepting Islam and that
uh
that's great because I I remember I was
speaking to a few guys in the warm about
it and then and Joel messaged me and
we've been speaking back and forth about
a few things you know and uh me and him
spoke about a week ago and we decided
that there was a one's diagram which is
the the app I'm watching Once that's up
and I can take my foot off the gas a bit
me and Hammer are going to do an in-pre
in person show in Dubai so it's crazy
you know all these these things are
occurring and everything's getting so I
guess you could see good for me my
life's going really well and it's it's
crazy because
only a year ago man you're sitting there
and you're like I'm never gonna have a
wife I'm never going to have a house I'm
never going to have friends because even
when I Revere at all the friends I had
they don't want to speak to me anymore
as soon as I stopped going to nightclubs
it was very apparent they didn't want to
be my friend anymore so your friends in
the secular World they just want you
there as a body so they can go to a club
and get what they actually want which is
some
female you know it's interesting I'll
say this you know the word civilization
so because they always do this leave it
in plain sight things civil means
secularly organized and isolation means
in the process of becoming so the word
civilization means in the process of
becoming secularly organized you know
but all these these old things have died
off and it's been a hard few months for
me because I really treat it with
sincerity so to start getting up in the
morning for Fajr you know it's difficult
at the start to give up all the the
female like because my big one my big
advice was always I guess you could say
the the women's side of things just
because you're young and you know you're
a guy you have instincts and you don't
see an alternative what's crazy actually
is even though I didn't towards the end
I really didn't like the free love
fornication
um thing that was pushed the idea and
it's crazy looking back the idea of
waiting till marriage didn't even cross
your mind because this secular world had
not demonized it but they just made it
seem so they kind of made it a joke as
if it's not the only way that it can
work and and go well
so the past fewons have been a bit
difficult but it's good you know because
so for example you give up the woman
side of things well now you have more
energy but then you've got to get up in
the morning for Fajr so it's different
it's different tricky things because
then you have more energy you can't get
to bed at night so you're up till two in
the morning with all this extra energy
and so there's little struggles but it's
going so well you know as good as
martial arts fantastic and I think what
I want to do and I think why a lot of
revers come out Islam with such
sincerity is because we've seen the
other side you know because for a lot of
born Muslims they've never experienced
the Haram secular do as thou well life
and they go well maybe it might be worth
it you know a woman marries a man things
don't go well she gets divorced she
might think of delving into that world
and there's a river who's experienced
that and I don't want to say fortunately
but I'm in an interesting position where
I've kind of you know exalted all those
passions like I I was never a single guy
I was never really shy of money I've
always done well in a business sense and
to see us how fruitless that endeavor is
I I don't when I see it being pushed on
Islam I want to hammer it so quickly
because a lot of these guys have never
experienced it and they always sell
under Freedom you know they'll sell
women taking their hijab office freedom
and I go no
what's free about you being treated as a
vessel for weak men's lust and being
passed around and selling photos of
yourself online for Bitcoin on only fans
that's not Freedom what's freedom is
being treated like a human being and
going out covered and being able to to
be respected you know and I always
Hammer these things home because I know
how bad they get
um so I think that's that's my goal in
terms of spreading the dealers just to
ensure that these things aren't that's
why I'm making diagram man because when
I go on the internet I can see it on
Instagram now they're trying to get men
to fight with women you'll see posts
where a woman's like and I don't even
think they're real I think it's Bots
that make this but a woman will post a
post on Instagram and it'll be like when
you when he wants to marry you but he
doesn't have 500k for a house at 19
manner of scum and then you see the
comments in Muslim matter Muslim women
are arguing and I can't stand it because
Islam is clearly the truth and like I
don't want to sound too extreme but like
Over My Dead Body that's going to occur
you know I will defend the religion
until I until I go to the Hereafter
because it has stood so strong that was
the only the last hope not the lasso but
the only hope for me and the truth and I
I Over My Dead Body will I see it so
varied you know so you answered my next
question pretty much your friends they
really didn't take too well to it were
their success and some of them that you
had them to think was the purpose of
life why are we here you know to get
them to kind of consider and how about
your parents how do they take to your
decision it's interesting mom because
like none of the friends really stuck
about in fact they don't they don't
they're not respectful but like I had
friends who I was best friends with for
five years and as soon as I stopped
wanting to go to a club and drinking
alcohol
and fornicate not only did they stop
speaking to you but they start
bad-mouthing you publicly and even were
you ever a friend in the first place and
I don't think it is I think and there's
the the saying that I I a rotten tree
can't bear good fruits and a good tree
can't bear bad fruits and I Think Jesus
Pieces people on this is more biblical
but he said that there was a story of
where a man built a house on Sand and
the winds came and the the storm blew
and the house came down
and another man built his house on a
rock and when the Thunder and the winds
came it stood and I think a lot of these
old friendships you had were built on
Sand and it was built on I want someone
to be with so I'm not alone when I'm in
a club taking drugs and sterily
fornicating with women and when you stop
doing that there's no support and they
do the opposite they back bite because
and I think what it is I think they see
that your life's getting better but they
don't have the confidence to take the
shahada you know or they don't they're
not willing to put away their Earthly
Pleasures to to look into the truth
one thing that's quite sad and I don't
want to say sad to a degree because I
have through the internet you can meet
people like when in human history could
I have met you you know it's there is an
equal and opposite reaction to
everything but I haven't told my parents
and it's not because they're bad I'm
just
the amount of propaganda they've been
fed I don't you don't know how they'll
take it and they're not bad people it's
just but if you've been told Islam is
bad Islam is bad Islam is bad
I don't wanna you know because I'm still
in a vulnerable position I still live
with them
um and I don't I don't want to bring it
up you know but that's fine it's not a
bigger I don't think people are bad I
just think that they're brainwashed to a
degree
do you get worried about them coming
across any of your videos
to a degree but I think I think one
thing I will say and people ask me this
about spreading Dean and people have
said would you ever do public Dean you
know would you ever would you ever go in
public and speak about Islam in Scotland
then I say no I'd probably get stabbed
but I think the way you do it is you
just set an example and I I always say
that the prophet peace be upon him if he
had the same teachings that he was
sloth
um lustful lazy
um overweight didn't back up anything he
said no one would listen to him I think
the reason people listen to people is
because they they they set such a good
example and I think inshallah that maybe
in two to three years once they see the
family that I have in Shalon they say
the fruits of Islam it's going to be
very hard to criticize because if you
see a young guy go from yes you can be
smart and a nice person but when you do
these Haram things Trouble Comes to the
doorstep you know and if you see that go
away and you see wow he's got more
energy he's happier he's more moral he
lies less he has a beautiful family
which isn't riddled with sin or better
yet it's not a relationship with his
wife which was built on Sand with
fornication and just consuming each
other I think it would be hard for them
to refute that you know so I think with
everything it's just a matter of
you don't want to be a leader but I
think being the best possible example
you can and then people will
instinctively follow you so I think I
think over the course of time you're
going to see a lot of guys like me
revert to Islam and I think that's why
I'm so vocal about these things because
I know there's loads of guys out there
who are in my shoes and feel that
there's no hope and if I can publicly
come on to these platforms and share my
experience it might just click in their
head as to what the next step is so I
think it's always a matter of just
setting the best example you can it's
hard sometimes because you know for the
past like just little things like with
all the business things I'm doing and
all the systems I'm setting up how do
you rewire your head to believe in
yourself and then when things get
stressful how do you stop yourself going
back to Old Habits instead of medicating
your fear and your anxiety with free
love or substances stop that and still
continue going forward
um it has been difficult and it can get
quite sad sometimes because you're
worried and you're not sure what's going
on and you don't have anyone to talk to
because everyone around you has been
brainwashed Islam is bad you know it but
that makes you a stronger man you know
yeah from the man
well I'm really that's amazing to see if
someone like yourself who obviously is
Young and you have so much uh in front
of you so much of the Temptations and
then you uh get influenced by an
islamophobe who actually changed changed
his ways and now you end up uh
accepting Islam you're here with us
sharing your story and then from being
programmed Islam is bad Islam is bad
Islam is bad to now actually even giving
dawah so much so that you are developing
uh an app dawa what's it called
as the only Haram free social media on
the planet where you go on because I
always thought this like I think if
if adults have been
explained things fairly and and a 20
year old man someone comes to him and
goes here's a loan for a car and here's
an only fans and he goes okay I think
that's fair because you're accepting it
but if you see like young kids now look
at like five-year-olds are on Tick Tock
and if you make an account what's the
algorithm pushing you just women doing
degeneracy promotion of the generacy
promotion of Haram and I don't know man
like something set off in me when I went
on Instagram and know that my my
algorithms change to mostly Islamic
content I can see the festering of that
little chatan where it's men posting
stuff about
oh you shouldn't get married and women
and then women are posting things about
how men ain't anything and and you can
see Muslim women becoming more
provocative and revealing and nipping it
in the bud so on on diagram because I
don't have any rebar I don't have any
investors I'm never making it
even if a company like BlackRock came to
me with a trillion dollars and wanted to
invest I would never accept it so what
it is is you go on diagram there's no
Haram there's no nudity there's no
degeneracy there's no lies there's no I
arguing or anything it's funny because I
got striked on YouTube twice when I
first started uploading videos I've only
got six videos up and I got strike twice
and I thought because YouTube striked me
for talking about
um or I mentioned something that
involves thingy and I just thought
in fact what it was there was a stream I
did and I didn't I mentioned that I did
not like the fact that if I uh
a young Muslim girl goes on Twitter and
she types in hashtag hijab pornography
comes up and I thought that in essence
is child molestation I don't like that
and YouTube sent me an email with a
strike and he said you have been
sexualizing younger people and I thought
you will allow cardi B wap on YouTube
which in essence just teaches women to
be prostitutes for free and I think I
don't know why I've always thought this
but the guys at YouTube and these people
this is a message for everybody these
guys who run these because it can seem
overwhelming nowadays seems like
everything's against you but these guys
who run these systems they're just men
they're just guys like you and actually
they're guys with Allah not behind them
you have the you have the upper hand so
I decided to make diagram it was a huge
risk I pretty much went bankrupt doing
it but it's going out now martial law
it's fantastic it was a great strength
that could test a character and it's a
platform where we have our own live
streaming servers so for example if a
guy like you wanted to go on and live
stream you're not going to get sentences
you're not going to get banned
and it's a place where kids can go and
be safe and protected it's a place where
you can go learn things that are
fruitful and prosperous I always use the
example of the chatan what he does is he
kind of gives you a rebubble on your
soul and I go I got a message from a
Muslim woman uh when I was doing a live
stream and she said I'm struggling now
because I want to get married but I
can't find a husband who's suitable
and she's like I'm dealing with these
Temptations of like fornication and
stuff and I said
what should tan does is he will take
something that you want and you'll give
it to you now but with interest on it
just like alone just like a Haram loan
so you want a husband you want a
fruitful marriage with healthy peers
children that takes sacrifice it takes
diligence it takes patience it takes in
essence an upgrading of your character
so it can be hard to attain so what he
will do is he'll give you something like
that now in the form of fornication
actually you think that if you fornicate
it will ice it will and medicate your
loneliness and your pain but what it
does is you engage in it and it just
temporarily makes you feel better but
then it sinks you lower but there's
interest on it you have to pay interest
on it so now when a man who's righteous
and strong on the dean and PS he comes
along and he wants to marry you well no
he doesn't because you've engaged in it
so with a lot of these things that are
pushed us shaitan gives you something
that you want but it's it's fruitless
it's sterile it's dead you know the the
marriage will have fruits of peers
children and a strong bond for life or
as fornication gives you nothing but
takes everything you know and the
diagram is a platformer none of that's
promoted none of that is exalted or
because that's one thing I never
understood was I get if you fall for
scams like in the west if you fall for
things like
murdering your Offspring for an Audi on
finance and a holiday in Ibiza but if
you want to publicly promote that and
push it I don't have any tolerance for
that and I don't take sympathy with him
meter so so diagram is a huge step in
the right direction and one of the
reasons that I'm proud of it is because
it sets an example for other people when
things hit you and you feel panicked and
you feel afraid if someone else has
taken that same emotion and he's he's
Twisted it and he's thrown it back at
them and created his own and I think
you're going to see a spiraling effect
just like Andrew with his his online
education platform a lot of young people
get into debt quarter of a million debt
to earn money which they'll never be
able to pay back so he created his own
you want to publicly promote every sin
under the planet and mock things that
are good and righteous well I'll create
my own and I think as time goes on
you're going to see a lot more of that
and I think that's the way to go I think
what they try to do is they try to get
you to think you're a victim I think
they do this with Idols if you put like
we were saying earlier with meet a
celebrity if you put these people on a
pedestal you'll never even consider that
you could compete with them you know if
you look at Elon with Twitter or
Zuckerberg with Facebook what people
think there's some Demi God that you can
compete with and I don't and I think
that's why when you don't have these
Idols you don't see yourself as any
different and you'll go for it so as it
was crazy because it was a very Rocky
time I spent all the money I had getting
up without debt because I want to back
up my word
and uh financial trouble came a few
people helped out and now it's it's
going ahead martial law is fantastic and
uh it makes me feel proud and I'm very
happy for for everyone who's going to
get on it because look I guess hard
nowadays a lot of parents but both of
them have to work do you leave your kids
with Tick Tock where they're going to be
fed lies well no you don't have to worry
about that you have somewhere that's
safe so it's great it's very relieving
the past two to three weeks we're quite
worrying because you're competing with
such big platforms and my bank account
isn't as big as elons but it's finally
going up mashallah which is fantastic
yeah keep me posted I'd like to see when
this uh is out I'm really proud to see
young Brothers like yourself who are
seeing the importance of uh sharing uh
as I often say if you care you share so
you're sharing the dean now and at such
an early stage now that you just
accepted Islam and you're really
passionate now about daoos putting
something together as diagram I'm
curious uh since you're in Scotland
there I think good friend of mine also I
don't know if you've heard of Sheikh
Abdul Rahim green I think he's in uh
Scotland Scotland have you heard of him
I haven't heard of him no I haven't
heard of them unfortunately yeah uh if
you look him up shake Abdul Rahim green
you have ayura have you heard of ayera
sapiens Institute
who runs a sapiens Institute there in
your neck of the woods how far are you
from London
um maybe about a three hour flight maybe
two hours right it's not like okay well
London's still in the UK I could drive
down it would maybe take about 10 12
hours but I don't mind yeah these are a
good educational Pro good educational
institutes that are out there and I
think uh there if I if I was out there
I'd be uh collaborating working with
these brothers good Brothers you need
that support mechanism that support
group uh to help you and and um these
these uh sapiens institutes definitely
have the sources and uh abdulrahim green
definitely look them up and uh I think I
believe abdulrahim is there in Scotland
I like to make the connection with you
guys uh he's uh he's somebody who's been
around a long time and I think you also
benefit tremendously from he might even
be your your neighbor how somewhere
there in Scotland oh I'll reach out to
him on Instagram yeah I get the chance
because I think the community is huge
you know I don't think uh just an attack
a side note when you look at how now
like one Brothers in London at
University
your sisters in an apartment somewhere
working some job and the two apparently
everyone's so fractured and split and I
don't think people are meant on I think
what happens is people get isolated and
they start medicating just like I said
earlier with you want something and
shaitan gives you something now you want
to be connected you want to be
surrounded by people in your community
who are good people and you don't really
get that as much now and I think what
happens then is people medicate the
isolation with things like men will
medicate the fact they don't have a wife
with porn the the woman will medicate
the fact they don't have a husband with
Tick Tock and they'll scroll all day and
let and demons infect their mind so I
think
building a strong community and having
Brothers next to you who you trust my
litmus test has always been could I
leave them with my wife and my bank card
for a weekend and I I can't it's so
crazy because when I went from high near
and Western people just like I said they
don't care about you they just want to
use you for an external result and to
have brothers now who like I've only
known for two months and have helped me
more and I've helped them more than
friends I had for 10 to five years you
know I think the community thinks a huge
part of this I'll definitely be reaching
out to these people uh that would be
great because if you become a better
person then if it benefits everybody you
know because then the people you're
surrounded by see it they know that
you'll know them by their fruits if your
fruits become better it will start to
radiate and it is sticky it starts to in
a good way infect the people around you
you know so it's always a positive to to
keep finding people who you want to be
like or finding people you admire and
people who are strong on the dean so
that's certainly something I I want to
do
good talking with you my brother thanks
for sharing your story with us inshallah
God willingness could be a benefit for
so many people out there to help get
them to think purpose of life why I've
been creative why I'm here like you did
inshallah Islam is bad Islam is bad
programming can get out of their mind
and they can take a step forward to
really investigating like you did and
I'll close with this I think you made a
statement you said I'd be a liar after
reading the Quran if I didn't accept
Islam something like that is that
correct yeah 100 I think all of the
the problems I had and all the confusion
I had whether it be from a theological
standpoint a moral standpoint a
community standpoint uh I I I'm not
gonna lie I am one of the biggest
Advocates and I love Sherry a lot and
I'm glad you never got into it today or
it would have been a five hour show from
Community marriage anything every single
thing in the Quran and the hindis and
the prophet peace be upon made absolute
sense and I would all and against the
saying I might be wrong but I'm not
lying and I I can tell you after reading
the Quran and the stories of the Prophet
peace be upon him if I didn't accept
Islam I would have seen myself as a liar
and I think that has far like I think
people think they get away with lies but
I don't think you do I think if you if
you hurt someone you hurt yourself when
you attack someone you attack yourself
when you
um
I've never done this obviously but if
you molest someone you're actually
molesting yourself because it stays in
your brain when you lie to someone else
you stop trusting yourself you know so
if I didn't accept Islam I would have
seen myself as a liar and I've seen all
the opposition to it you know and I
don't I'm going to publicly mention
names because I don't want to do that
but when I was on the fence I started
looking at people who are very
anti-islam let's say you know I think
people can like there's certain big guys
out there who may be apostates or
something to do with wood and I would
watch their stuff
and it made no sense to me it didn't
make any sense at all so I looked at the
opposition I bought all the banned the
books in the Bible uh the the the
um the uh what's the word of the
evolution side of things didn't make any
sense to me when I seen the Quran it's
like box tech box tech box Tech if I
don't accept that I'm a liar and I don't
like to see myself that way so so yeah
it was it was incredible the best
decision I've made in my life martial
law nothing comes close most people just
uh before we conclude most people
because of the many misconceptions when
people when you say the Divine guidance
of the the Sharia people think of the
penal code which is makes up to about
one two percent of the actually uh what
it's what is covered in in uh in Islam
it's very small percentage that focuses
on these deterrence that are in place to
keep the criminals and everyone in place
but you know the the Sharia God's Divine
Law came to preserve these five
fundamental things your religion your
connection with your creator that pure
monotheism to protect your protect your
intellect that's why certain things are
prohibited like alcohol to protect your
wealth and that's where you talk about
interests and all of these things so
um and then to protect uh
your
um your human life you know the sanctity
of human life uh so people don't talk
about prayer fasting this should be a
charity they get caught up with the the
penal code and they scare people and now
they forget about all these beautiful
things family home uh the preservation
of of of the most the most important
thing is the family right yeah how to
have a fat how to run a business how all
these things are laid out in the Divine
uh guidance and it's it's all there so I
think um just to close on this um yeah I
think someone said that the Quran
teaches you things as small as how to
brush your teeth or clean yourself and
things as big as how to run a
civilization how to run the world how to
function on a huge scale and I would
want to say because I think for a lot of
of and I've noticed this I pick up on
things quite quickly martial art which
I'm I'm glad I understand yeah that's
good
um I can see a lot of Muslims seem
hopeless and they think every things
against us everything promoted us
against us I really think you know you
can give people and like I said you know
when you give people the secular
um hedonistic lifestyle you have to pay
interest on it you know so guys this is
one thing that happened to me is you'd
fornicate with a woman and your your
relationships built on Sand and then
eight months down the line you're in
love with each other but it's built on
Sand and it crumbles and I think you're
going to see a lot of people in the west
Gohan I was sold this as a freedom and
now it's a chain that has enslaved me
and even little things like the birth
rate if you want to push LG TV and drop
your birth rate well Muslims aren't
doing that and there's a lot of people
in the west who want to complain about
things like migration or something and
it's like no you decided that you wanted
to believe lies and go to war on
countries that didn't want to and then
when they come over here because you've
destroyed their country and you decide
to do sodomy and they don't you're not a
victim but I think what you're going to
see is you're going to see
I wouldn't be surprised an engine I
would love to see this I would publicly
make this bet that I think in the next
five to ten years you will see the
return of a caliphate somewhere I really
think that's going to happen I think
Sharia law returning is not as far away
as people think and if you look at the
end times prophecies a lot of people
have this mindset which I understand
that oh Iman Market is going to return
and he will restore order for seven
years and people forget there has to be
a caliph before that there has to be
caliphates before he returns if you look
at the story of how his three sons argue
so people who's gonna do it you know I
think you're going to see that is this
if you look at the West as it just
implodes on itself because you can give
people these lies you can give men
pornography when they're seven years old
and you can give women only fans and you
can get everyone in debt but eventually
you don't have anyone who wants to work
anymore you don't have any people you
don't have a birth rate you don't have
workers and your system collapses and if
you look at how the dollar is collapsing
is going to fill that void Muslims are
the only the only religion with a strong
birth rate at the moment and I really
think inshallah you're going to see a
caliphate somewhere soon and I think
once that happens and people see the
fruits of her uh uh islamically
organized government with Sharia law is
not what I was told and in fact they
struggle with none of the things that
are currently killing us slowly and
you're going to see a huge wave of of I
guess you can say kufar reverting to
Islam and I think there's a lot of Hope
at the end of the tunnel every every
action has an equal and opposite
reaction you know when they give you all
these bad things like I just mentioned
there's also an equal and opposite
reaction we're in human history could me
and Eddie have linked up and shared this
message with hundreds and thousands of
people we couldn't of before when could
a 21 year old Reaver compete with MAO
you couldn't before but now you can and
I think and I can see this as a Reverb
is that the the pendulum is going to
swing the whole other way you know I
think maybe a lot of born Muslims are
like well you know so maybe if people my
daughter had a boyfriend but she not and
the reverse will come in and go all
fornication should be illegal like the
pendulum swings the whole other way I
think you're going to see a lot of that
in the future and I don't think it's
longer for some country adopts Sharia
law and from there I think it's going to
be a Snowball Effect and and countries
will start adopting it and popping up
um all across the globe so I think there
is a lot of Hope at the end of the
tunnel people will sell you the idea of
hopelessness because if you don't
believe there's any possibility that you
can Thrive you'll give up before you
even started so don't believe that when
people want to give you a narrative that
there's no point in trying everything's
Doom and Gloom that's false and the
whole point of that is to stop you from
getting off your backside and doing
something about it and I think there's
huge Prosperity coming in the future I
think a huge opportunity for people
coming in the future and it's all them
to whether you want to stay strong on
The Dean in my opinion if you can refute
no matter how
oops
strong and clear and how many times
you've thrown these Haram things if you
can resist Hard Times create strong men
you know if I ever became a successful
man I'm never going to indulge again you
know these hard times will make you a
strong man and I think there's loads of
prosperity for people in the future so
don't let that hopeless nothing matters
everything's doing Gloom get to you
because it makes you a victim if you're
a victim you you blame someone else for
your problems and the problem with that
is you can never make the change because
you've decided in your mind that is on
other people
your changes are beholden to other
people's Authority and that's not true
you have when you do Haram no one made
you do it but then on the back end of
that when you do Halal no one can stop
you doing it you can make a change you
can thrive in this world even though it
seems so Bleak and so Misty and dark
it's like through the dark there is a
world weighing and that's where you will
call home so don't let that hopelessness
get to you because there is huge
prosperity
um out there for people who seek it in
my opinion
yeah the beautiful martial law this is
uh
couple things I wanted to mention the
when I heard you say from the smallest
to the biggest it reminded me of one of
the companions of prophet Muhammad when
he was asked he said by a anonymouslum
he said uh well your Prophet teaches you
everything it was just like he said yes
everything even how to go to the
bathroom so if we're taught how to go to
the bathroom
and for many people this is odd what do
you mean how to go to the bathroom you
know and if you go um one time Michelle
was asked he said why do Muslims wash
themselves and he said he gave an
example he said if you were if you were
to take a newspaper and you threw it out
there and you said hey son go get me
fetch me that newspaper and then then
you went to get the newspaper and next
thing you know there was some dung from
a dog on there and now you got it on
your hand and he said he said go ahead
now how would you clean it would you
wipe it off or wash it off he said
because no matter how much you want you
you wipe it off what's going to happen
it's still going to stink right so
people don't know the basics of washing
their rear end and Islam teaches you how
to how to go to the bathroom so that's
the from the smallest to the biggest on
how to worship your creator how to be
successful in this life and the next
everything is laid out in between and
that's what's fascinating you and people
like like yourself and the not yet
Muslims who are out there because
everyone as I say has the potential to
do what you did because yesterday you
were someone body who wasn't doing the
submission and surrender to the crater
but now you are in Islam so just like
there is a potential for you and you did
it that's why that was so important that
we get out there and share and sharing
like we are right now this message so
more people can go ahead and wake up and
get out of the uh the the the the Matrix
or whatever you want to call it the
satanic influences that's what I call it
the satanic influence that's out there
and pulling people away with all the
distractions and to see you're a living
proof right there a young man such as
yourself who can go ahead and give up
all of this out there and these are the
the young men who will be shaded under
the shade under the day of judgment that
we know the shade in one of those
categories is a young man who worshiped
his Creator God Almighty Allah and gave
up all of this stuff you know as a
sacrifice
just to close on this again like they're
so mad and I don't know how much detail
I want to get into them about but like
there's so many things that have
happened in the past three months
where I can't see anything else as being
Divine and like so many I guess you
could say Miracles have occurred in the
past three months has been crazy because
like I'll go back to the diagram because
financially it nearly got me bankrupt
because again you're competing with all
these big guys I'm not a millionaire or
anything so it's like and I was in a
position where I couldn't fathom it was
the only time in my life I was like I'm
screwed I have no money left I have no
one to talk to because if I tell my
parents and I explain to them the Islam
thing about they kick me out
and then you make Dua and and what I've
always noticed is just before something
great happens it's the Temptations get
worse they get harder and it's like
should I just go do this or do that and
I refuted them even though they were so
intense and like it was pressuring on my
back and I refuted them
and then these I guess you could say
Miracles occurred where I couldn't find
them how I got pulled through at the
other end you know and even things that
my shahada was so effortless and smooth
you know you would have thought I would
have been like well I'm not sure let me
think about it which is yes
so the I can't deny that there is an
Almighty Creator the deserving of uh of
worship and it's it's uh it's fantastic
martial arts uh again and I say this a
lot it's the best decision I've made in
my life and I hope that the people see
this don't take I understand I can
sometimes speak in a way that can appear
arrogant I don't mean to do that when I
get fired up about things it's not
because I have an ego it's I care about
things I really care and to see you know
just little things to see your parents
or people you love fall victim to these
satanic spells I couldn't it's like my
Skin's on fire I can't see people
take it and I will get angry I can get
fired up I'm sweating now as I'm saying
this and I don't I don't be able to get
the wrong impression of my message and
people who are on the fence about
revering it's crazy because I've already
had about 10 15 guys who have particular
shahada and they've told Allah
who had uh said I had a huge influence
on it so
um so yeah it's uh everything's going
swelling well it's been nothing more
than a pleasure speaking to you man it's
uh it's it's amazing likewise so people
have that decision and choice to see
young men going down the tubes going
down the toilet on one side you have
debauchery you have fulfilling your
lustful desires partying drugs and you
know test driving women on the other
side what you're doing connection with
your creator trying to live a morally
upright life really caring for yourself
in humanity so I think the choice is
clear and you made it and Allah
inshallah more people can go ahead and
make the right decision to think about
the purpose of life why am I here before
death comes and it's too late you can't
go back to take retake the test
yeah 100 100 yeah
um I was going to say something I
completely forgot
um yeah you know what as well like and
this is one thing for the guys who are
like okay you've given up all these
Haram things is it better without it
it's not even close you know the prophet
had a saying that was I don't just it's
ironic because I've done all three now
but it's like don't discuss things uh
don't discuss marriage business and
traveling until they're finalized and I
guess I've already done all three which
is I'm still learning right but I'm I
guess you could say engaged at the
moment and the relationship I have with
the woman I'm engaged to is it's not
even close to what you had before you
know these these castles built on Sand
were the the basis of your relationship
is consuming each other for your own
desires to stop that and replace it and
do it in a Halal way it's like it Bears
fruits and it's 10 million times more
fulfilling I think this is why people
get addicted to things because they do
these things thinking it will fulfill
them and it never does so they keep
going and going and going and going
until they're on a ditch your 50. so
when you're replace these Haram things
with the alternative and Halal where
it's so much better so much more
fulfilling is is incredible martial art
again it's all down to the choices that
people make no one makes you do it no
one puts a gun to your head and stops
you doing Halal no one forces you to do
Haram it's all on you and there's a big
push to get people to blame other people
nowadays for their problems and blame
groups of people for their problems but
those people don't make you do it you do
it to yourself and that's liberating
because then you as a Divine man Allah's
highest form of creation have the
ability to do with your own free will
the exact opposite you know so so yeah
that's um I guess that's all I have to
say
um is uh incredible man
we're locked in the bless you guide you
the creator of Heavens on Earth thank
you very much for sharing your story My
Brother
I'm here for you as your brother man if
you need anything let me know and
likewise I'm likewise all right
I'm sure all of you know Eddie from the
D show and I'm sure that you've all
heard about the dean center now you
don't want to miss on this opportunity
the brother has been around for a long
time when I became Muslim that was a
show that I used to watch it was one of
the shows that I actually was
interviewed on and since then I've kept
in touch with Eddie and we've cooperate
and participated in many things we got
alhamdulillah by the blessing of Allah
now you guys have to do your part this
is for the ummah there's so many people
in this world who need The Message of
Islam but the question is not what
you're gonna do what are you going to do
with your money with what you have what
are you going to do to help the ummah to
help someone who's been around for 20
years doing dawa you've enjoyed the
shows you've enjoyed the interviews
you've enjoyed now it's your turn
support the dean Center
[Music]
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you